today and this week is about all of you
it's about your futures your dreams your
aspirations your goals be as a parent in
the community I think this is awesome
because viewers will know their parents
across the United States are celebrating
change that a movement has begun that we
will demand changes and choices in our
community we believe that every single
family and student has the right to the
choice of a highly effective school in
Los Angeles fact that he had the courage
to come stand here today with a school
choice movement that may be politically
popular writ large but inside the school
district it's not the it's not the most
popular constituency it just goes to say
that we're lucky to have a
superintendent who will stand up for the
interests of kids even on days that it's
hard we also have charter schools
outside the district melted private
schools in here and home schoolers
online learning not everybody needs the
same thing everybody in this room is
doing what they want for their children
or their offering it up for family
this is a party today trying to energize
you it might be a fight tomorrow and
it's worth the fight applause aw Thank
You Los Angeles look at that press a key
yeah